foreign
get out of debt and stay out of debt
because that way you have control of
your life some stupid but bank or car
company doesn't have control of your
life
and you have control of the most
powerful wealth building tool
that you could possibly have and that's
your income
when you give all your income to a
stupid butt Bank you have no money
and you have couch payments and you have
cell phone payments and you have car
payments and you have Sallie Mae
payments and payments and payments and
payments and payments and you work your
butt off and you get to the end of your
life broke and you say gosh I hope the
government which is well known for its
ability to handle money will take care
of me this is not a plan America
instead we teach you to actually get out
of debt
quit worshiping at the altar of the
great FICO
and that means that it changes what you
use banks for
you know what I use banks for
checking account
that's it
got a debit card on it
got several of them several banks for
that matter a lot of money in Banks but
for running this business and for
running our real estate properties and
for running our lives and so forth but
that's basically all A bank's good for
and guess what when you start using a
bank just for that you realize how bad
Banks really suck
that they're absolutely the most
horrendous industry when it comes to
customer service they treat you like
garbage it treats you like a name and so
we recommend small Community Banks
Regional banks at the most and or credit
unions we tell you to stay away from
these Behemoth Banks because they're
going to treat you like crap and they
don't care
if you work for Bank of America you
should get a good job
if you work for Wells Fargo you should
get a good job working for a good
company not the one you're working for
they're awful and here we go again like
the sixth time in five years or the
fifth time in six years Here We Go Again
George tell them what's happening this
is from Wells Fargo right now from NPR
here's the headline Wells Fargo to pay
3.7 billion dollars settling charges it
wrongfully seized homes and cars wow
it's a thousand Millions 3.7
000 million
that's got to be pretty bad so the cfpb
Consumer Financial Protection
accidentally do this once wow
cfpb can do that they just ordered them
to pay billions and fines for this and
that Wells Fargo agreed to it which
means I'm guilty which means they did it
gosh they would not have agreed to it if
they didn't do it wow you don't pay 3.7
billion just to keep the cfpb happy you
go to court
if you're right but they're wrong they
did it and the cfpb knocked them in the
head this is awesome so here's what
happened people had their cars
wrongfully repossessed by Wells Fargo
and the bank took actions that resulted
in borrowers wrongfully losing their
homes according to the order from the
cfpb other customers were wrongly and
improperly charged overdraft fees on
their checking accounts
yikes Wells Fargo's rinse and repeat
cycle of violating the law has harmed
millions
millions millions
more than one of American families the
CP cfpb director
said uh reho I don't know how you
pronounce that oh Chopra maybe that
sounds a Chopra or something yeah wow
that's pretty wild and some other terms
of the order of Wells Fargo will pay 2
billion to millions of customers who
were harmed and the bank will pay 1.7
billion dollar fine
this is wild
and uh it's it's weird that there's such
repeat offenders you'd think they'd
learned their lesson after having to pay
which tells you how much money they are
making off of you America if they've got
Just 4 billion laying around to pay
fines and they just move on with their
day
and they build big big buildings
at Wells Fargo don't you what's that
Tuesday
that's a drop in the bucket for these
big Banks just another day at the bank
and tomorrow you'll see their name on
the newest stadium in your town
going well how is this possible yeah
because they're screwing everyone over
with this kind of behavior
the bank framed of the settlement as a
way to move forward
and reform the company's Scandal ridden
past nothing says we're doing great and
not guilty like we will continue paying
billions of dollars to make ourselves
look good
goodness gracious
okay
well if you bank with Wells Fargo now's
a good time to not bank with Wells Fargo
uh one time to look for a new bank those
the other one there was
it was Bank of America that actually
foreclosed on a house that had no debt
on it in Florida they did that so I
always said you know we've done research
and 100 of the foreclosures occur on a
home with a mortgage that's actually not
true there was that one time at Bank of
America foreclosed on a house that had
no mortgage on it in Florida and boy did
they get their butt suit off for that
one oh God but these guys are they're
they're they're like big Tech big big
fintech here is uh you know if you're
Google if you're Apple you're larger
economically than most countries
so you're somewhat insulated
if you're Wells Fargo you're someone
insulated they had a thing that wasn't
24
000 employees you have to look that old
article up that's like four years ago uh
24
000 employees had falsely opened
accounts and the customers names if I
remember the story crack
so these are Bankers trying to hit their
quota and get their sales bonuses
because that's really all a banker is
now is a bad salesman
and in order to hit their Branch quotas
24
000 different employees at uh falsely
opened accounts in order to hit I I may
be a little bit off on the year or
whatever but I'm not off on the idea the
concept happened and it's one way to do
it this is that was also Wells Fargo
that's part of their Scandal written
past you guys
how do you survive as a like how do you
still have customers after all this and
people still go there and sign up for an
account today well knowing all this
there's a couple of ways to grow a
business one way you grow a business is
you do a great job serving
and you get bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger
you do a great job at your restaurant
and uh somebody wants you to open
another one and somebody wants you to
open another one and uh your sub
sandwiches are good and so then later on
your Jimmy John's right and so you do a
good job which Jimmy John's does a good
job right so they're franchised so you
serve the customer and you get big to
scale because you just keep doing the
right thing a lot the other way you can
grow a business which is the way this
one was grown is you buy up all the
competitors you take all your profits
and keep buying all the competitors and
you take your stinky horrible systems
and integrate them into every Bank you
bought
and then you did it and so what you're
doing now is screwing people with scale
and that's what these guys are they're
just um
guys if if it happened a couple of times
in a company the size of Wells Fargo
you would go well it's a it's a huge
company of course they're going to have
a couple of Bad actors
this was Millions
of you that are customers
millions of customers were harmed
how do you do that and even stay open
well because you people keep going over
there and running your dadgum checking
account because you think the little
Stagecoach is in your favor
they got the old timey little logo makes
you forget your old Tommy logo Millions
Millions
we're not going to fool me with the
Oregon Trail those people died of
dysentery okay we know how that ended
George Don't officially old no one knows
what the organ Trail is um I'm trying to
teach the young folks out there Oregon
Trail I had to throw it out you must
have been four when that was out yeah
just about four yeah good memory
computers were new
oh well the good news is America you
have a choice with where you bank and I
know it's a hassle to go like switch a
checking account but if it means staying
away from companies like this that treat
you like this it is worth an hour or two
of your time I don't I just don't grasp
why anyone still has an account at Wells
Fargo or Bank the only thing I can think
of is if you got a mortgage and it gets
sold to a different lender I'm talking
about your accounts your banking is
there yeah that doesn't make sense and
you know do better my car did not get
repoed I was not one of the millions wow
well it's because you own it because I
don't have anything to do with these
idiots